I personally feel it should have gotten
more love this award season do you agree
how do you feel about that I don't know
I think we've got enough from people's
uh love and appreciation it's just
everything is extra right now and we are
already very happy we are satisfied as
actors I think a good cinema doesn't
have a language and uh RR is an example
for that and I'm so proud and I'm so
happy that my director made me part of
such a movement and such a film I think
covered yes there was a bad dark season
but it also did something good for all
of us the cinema is becoming a global
Cinema it's no more Hollywood Bollywood
I'm so fortunate to be part of that